- [Sal] In this video,
we're going to talk a little
bit about ionic compounds,
and specifically we're
going to think about
the empirical formulas
for ionic compounds.
So the first thing you
might be wondering is
well, refresh me, Sal, on
what ionic compound is.
Well, we're going to be dealing with ions,
which you can view as the
charged versions of atoms.
So, if you start with a neutral atom,
the only way it gets charged
is if you are gaining
or losing electrons, and
that would make it an ion.
And then a compound, that tells us
that we're dealing with more
than one type of element.
So let's just get a little
bit of a refresher here.
So we've talked about this
in-depth in other videos,
but we know that atoms like to have
a full outer shell of electrons,
a full number of valence electrons.
Now, in most situations, that means
having eight valence electrons,
and that's why these noble
gases right over here
are considered to be so stable.
They're already very satisfied.
They have eight valence electrons.
They all have different
numbers of electrons,
but the outer shell is eight.
And the one exception
is when we're talking
about that first shell,
and once again, this is all review
that we've talked about in other videos.
That first shell is most stable
when it has two electrons,
and that's why helium is also so stable.
So in general, when atoms react,
they tend to react in a way that gets them
to either two electrons
in their first shell
or eight electrons in
any other outer shell,
whichever one is their outermost shell.
Now, how they get that, they can do that
in several different ways
and it really depends
on whether we're talking
about metals or non-metals.
So first, let me separate
the non-metals here.
So, hydrogen is a non-metal.
And then we'll come here
and this little staircase looking thing.
So everything to the right
and up of this dividing line
that I just drew, these
are all non-metals,
including hydrogen.
Now, when non-metals interact
to try to get to that full outer shell,
they tend to do it by sharing
electrons with each other.
For example, two hydrogens, each of which
have one outer electron,
well they can form
a covalent bond, which we
talk about in other videos,
and then they're each sharing
each other's electron,
so they can kind of pretend like they have
a full outer shell.
Now, it's different when we're
talking about a non-metal
interacting with a metal,
which we can generally refer to
the rest of the periodic table.
There's other further sub-classifications.
When you have a metal
interacting with a non-metal,
what typically happens
is that the non-metal
is actually going to gain electrons
to get to a full outer shell,
while the metal will lose electrons
to get to a full outer shell.
So I'll give you an example,
and I use this example a lot
and this is a common example
that gets us to table salt.
If you look at sodium right over here,
a neutral sodium atom
has one valence electron,
one electron in that third shell.
Well, the easiest way for it
to get to a full outer shell
is to give up that one electron,
and then it will have the same
number of electrons as neon.
It still has 11 protons,
which make it a sodium,
but it'll have the same
number of electrons as neon,
and then it will be happy.
So sodium tends to form
a sodium ion with a positive one charge.
Now, we can go on the other
side of the periodic table.
If we were to look at
chlorine right over here,
chlorine has seven valence electrons.
It has seven electrons
in that third shell.
Well, the easiest way for
it to get a full eight
is to nab an electron from someplace,
is to gain an electron.
So chlorine tends to take
electrons from other atoms
and forms a negative charge
and becomes the chloride anion.
Now, what do you think will happen
if you put a bunch of sodium
and a bunch of chlorine together?
Well, the chlorine's probably going to
take electrons from the sodium,
or the sodium is likely to
give electrons to the chlorine,
and then you have these two ions.
One is positively charged,
one is negatively charged.
They will be attracted to each other
and that's what forms the
ionic compound sodium chloride.
And this is the empirical
formula for table salt.
For sodium chloride, for every sodium ion,
you have a chloride ion.
It's interesting to note that even though
the sodium has a positive charge,
the chlorine, which is
now the chloride anion
has a negative charge, that
the ionic compound in total
has a neutral charge, which
is an interesting property
of these ionic compounds.